The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We want to
talk about theoretical models.
They tell us stories.
The key variables are very
much of interest-- growth,
inequality, poverty, but just
telling a story as elegant,
as it may be, even
with surprises does not
even necessarily tell us that
it matches up to reality,
and therefore, one might be a
little bit cautious in terms
of formulation of policy.
Now it is true that having
sort of a good conceptual
foundation, a good
well-articulated theoretical
model is a very important step.
I'm not demeaning
that step at all.
What I'm trying to say is
it's a very useful first step,
but in the literature
we're going
to review today, we've
gone beyond that,
and to try to take the next
step and see how well it fits.
And how are we going
to, quote, fit it?
We're going to take the assumed
micro-financial underpinnings
and estimate those
underpinnings,
and get the bulk of the key
parameters of the model pinned
down in that way
from the micro data.
There'll be a few
remaining parameters
that we can't get from household
choice or business choice,
and we'll calibrate those.
And then we'll
simulate the models
and get what the model would
predict for growth inequality--
income, savings,
labor's share of GDP,
and actually also some
of the key underpinnings
of each model, and
the first one it's
going to be the fraction of
households running businesses
and the second
one is going to be
the fraction of
households participating
in the financial sector.
So what do we do with these?
Each one, then,
after we get done
looking at the
goodness of fit, we
can do welfare analysis
of policy intervention.
The first model has,
to make it easier,
an exogenously expanding
financial sector
at exactly the rate
we see it in the data,
and that's going to
create winners or losers.
As the financial
system expands, we'll
get changes on the
extensive margin
because some households
will go into business.
We'll get changes as
wealth accumulates
in the amount to take
and invest in business,
and also because it's going to
be a general equilibrium model,
we're going to get changes in
equilibrium wages and interest
rates which have effects even
beyond the direct effects,
often quite big.
In fact, there's a debate,
depending on which political
position you take,
about trickle-down,
which is sometimes
taken negatively,
trickle-down meaning only
the rich benefit from various
things and the poor--
workers are lucky to get
anything, a better way
to say it is a rising
tide raises all boats.
The model kind of takes
a stand on these things,
and in particular,
the wage, when
you have financial
deepening, can go up,
and that is an enormous benefit
to poor people, even unskilled
poor people who have better
employment and better wage
opportunities.
The second welfare experiment
is when, in the second model,
the government takes
over the banking system.
I alluded to this at
the end of last time,
and again, when they
liberalized this system
and turned it back over
to the commercial sector,
that also creates welfare
gains, which can be quite large,
and we can--
the point is, we can use
each of these models,
if we believe the
model and we believe
more or less the numbers we
put in for the parameters,
we can quantify these
welfare gains and losses.
There's some corollaries
that come out of this.
First of all, growth
doesn't necessarily
have to go up as the
financial system expands.
We reviewed some
literature last time
about finance causes growth that
seemed plausible and reasonable
and at least at a
reduced form since it
seemed to fit the data.
But in the second model,
as opportunities expand,
you can create endogenously
more financial infrastructure,
but it comes at a cost.
And just like anything
else, investment not
may not pay off right away.
So some resources,
quote-unquote,
disappear in this creation
of financial infrastructure,
and so in effect, the
growth rate levels go down
and growth rates are
slower for a while
than they would have been
without the liberalization.
Another caveat
coming from the model
is, both models today
are transition models--
that is to say, they are
not yet in steady-state,
although if I remember,
I'll try to say something
about the steady states
of each of these.
And so in some
respects, the models
are not generating
stationary time series.
Implicitly when you run a
regression, OLS and so on,
you're kind of assuming
you're getting data drawn
from as stationary time series.
So we run regressions on some
of these model-generated data
where we know exactly what's
going on, and sure enough,
you get kind of spurious,
bogus, or erratic coefficients
on the very same regressions
that the literature has
been running with actual
cross-country data.
So it's sort of a caution.
Now toward the end, there's
a tendency to, in any class,
any lecture for any course,
you see models and you'll see,
oh, there's a model, let's
learn how to manipulate that one
and maybe do a few
extensions of it,
or a second class
with a second model.
Toward the end, I
will deliberately
try to engage you in a
comparison of these two models
to make the point that the
real research that goes on
is trying to decide not just
how to an extent a given model,
but sort of what
we learn overall.
It's not typically published,
this stuff, actually.
Mostly these conversations take
place in offices and hallways
or over beer and so on, but
it's actually a big part
of the research process.
So as an introduction overall,
a few words from a paper I
wrote with Hyeok
Jeong, which repeats
all what I've said already.
Basically we're not grabbing
parameters out of thin air,
we're going to estimate
them with the micro data.
We compare the
predictions of the model
with the actual dynamics.
There is a well-established
tradition in other sciences
that has to do with
model validation.
So it's quite common
to basically calibrate
the machine or the model
or the process, and then
sort of simulate and
see how well it works
without being recalibrated.
Or put another way, if you
have enough degrees of freedom
and enough parameters and
you're constantly tinkering,
there's a tendency to
be able to fit stuff.
You've seen this probably in
your first course in statistics
and ordinary least squares.
If you run out of degrees of--
you can fit-- align two points,
you can perfectly well--
or you can fit a polynomial
even with nonlinear data,
but then out of sample, you
want to predict some more
and it's just crazy,
it's just completely off.
So here, we followed the
tradition of kind of not--
deliberately not
using all of the data.
It is a matter of choice,
though, what data to use
and what to set aside, and
I could imagine more, quote,
experiments than
we actually did.
So there isn't a fixed
rule for how to do this,
and it's not even as
commonly used in economics
as I think it
probably ought to be.
And I guess you
know the main theme
today is this marriage
of theory and data.
Frisch very early on in
the '30s was a big champion
of the mutual penetration of
quantitative economic theory
with statistical observations.
I think that's actually on
the econometric cover, if not
their website.
And in particular, we're
somewhere between theory
without measurement and
measurement without theory.
A big controversy in
business cycle analysis
along that line, a big debate
between [INAUDIBLE] and Burns
and Mitchell.
OK.
So we're going to do
these two papers that
came from the literature.
It's kind of a plus and a minus.
One is Lloyd-Ellis
and Dan Bernhardt,
and the other is
Greenwood and Jovanovic.
Each tell a plausible
story about what
lies behind the growth
process and the relationship
between growth and equality,
financial deepening,
and those other
variables that I listed.
And we're going to try
to estimate those models.
Well, the negative
part of this thing
is we learned how to do
statistics and econometrics
in part through the
lens of these models
by realizing how problematic
certain parts of those models
are.
And I would not start this
way if I were starting over.
And as I go through
the lecture, I
will try to point out which
particularly worrisome
or problematic parts I
have in mind in terms
of taking these
models to the data.
But anyway, again, back
on the positive side,
that's literally what we did.
We adopted wholesale,
without any modification
or qualification,
exactly the equations
that these theoretical
authors used in their models.
Uh oh.
That's not good.
So Lloyd-Ellis and
Bernhardt, LEB for short,
there are three occupations--
farmers, workers, and
entrepreneurs, and it's
costly to set up a firm.
But these costs are like talent,
they vary with the individual.
The more talented you are,
the less costly it is.
It's assumed that the cumulative
distribution of talent
is distributed
according to capital H
here where x is
the level of cost.
And you have to be
careful with the notation
where we're talking
about densities
versus cumulative distributions,
so just kind of bear
that in mind.
There's also an initial
distribution of wealth
that starts off the model, G of
b where b is sort of bequest.
Just to alert you, this
model has a relatively naive
dynamic part.
People essentially live for
two periods-- they eat today
and they leave
money for their kids
or their tomorrow's next period
as if leaving a bequest, hence
the notation b for a Bequest.
So what earnings two people
have in a given period?
Farmers earn kind of a
subsistence living in farming,
and they carry their
wealth over and have it
at the end of the period.
Workers earn wages-- excuse me--
and entrepreneurs make profits.
Everybody has this
initial wealth
which can vary
across individuals
carried over to the end of
the period, essentially.
A little bit of an exception
for the entrepreneurs.
When Dan wrote his
model, he kind of
had in mind an earlier
development literature
which makes
agriculture out there
in the rural areas versus
factories and manufacturing
in the cities.
So they had in mind a kind
of cost of living adjustment,
so basically workers
earn their wage,
but they have to pay this
cost of living, which
gives a little bit advantage
to being in the subsistence
sector.
Actually, you can see
it right away down here,
if sort of in equilibrium to
have both farmers and workers
coexisting, these two equations
have to be equal to each other.
So as long as the
wage does not exceed--
the wage less this cost of
living does not exceed gamma,
then a household
would be indifferent
about whether to migrate
to the city for a wage
and pay that cost
versus stay in farming.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is this
going to be abstracting
all the way from land markets?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes it is.
And-- OK, let's get to the firm.
Well, let me just
follow up on that.
The model as estimated
and calibrated
will actually deliver the fact
that for fairly long periods
of time, the wage
stays relatively low
and you have all three sectors
coexisting, although there will
come this knife-edge time where
the wage starts to pop up,
and then quite
unrealistically there
should be no more farmers.
You would think
this model is doomed
to fail with that
kind of knife edge,
but surprisingly in Thailand,
there are still farmers,
but the wage did stay relatively
flat for quite a long time
and then grew rather quickly.
What about firms?
So firms maximize
basically profit.
The price of the output
or the consumption goods
is normalized to 1.
So firms have output,
which is produced
using capital and labor.
Labor can be hired.
Those are the workers, you
have to pay them a wage.
And capital, basically, is
coming out of initial wealth.
So capital and consumption
are kind of 1 to 1.
So you have your sort
of initial wealth,
and the capital has to
be financed by that.
Capital cannot
exceed that amount.
And actually, there's
this fixed cost,
and that also has to get paid.
There's a lot going
on right here,
because there's two constraints.
One is you have to
pay x to get started,
and the second is that
you can't borrow at all.
All the investment is
basically self-financed.
Now that said, you could imagine
kind of weakening this a bit
and allowing the amount
you could be borrowing
to be some multiple of
a b, and next class,
we'll talk about
many models that
do something exactly like that.
But for now, no credit at all.
So this just-- these costs
just subtract right off
of output as if at
the end of the period,
or b minus these
things is what you
have at the end of the period.
Then you get you get the
output and you pay the workers.
So the key in this
paper and so many
other papers is an occupation
choice map that really
summarizes the possibilities.
So the two key variables from
a household's point of view
is the initial
wealth that they have
at the beginning of the period--
it could be high or low--
and the setup cost x
to running a business.
And naturally, if your wealth
is high and your costs are low,
you're a talented person,
you're, say, not only
likely to go into business, but
that finance constraint is not
going to be binding either.
You're going to run the marginal
product of capital down to 1,
and you still have
more money left over,
so you kind of carry it off
to the end of the period.
There is a region
of lower wealth,
but yet somewhat
talented people who
are constrained
entrepreneurs, they
would actually like to employ
higher levels of capital k
than they are able to finance
out of their own wealth.
They would borrow if they could,
but there's no credit yet.
And actually, this straight
line is when they can't even
cover their setup
costs, or on the margin,
they're just able to
cover their setup cost
x out of their wealth b, and
there's nothing left over,
so they can't even run the
firm on the intensive margin.
And then the rest
of the guys, they're
kind of workers or
agriculturalists.
So the shape of this is
intuitively reasonable, right?
The higher is
wealth and the lower
is talent, the more likely you'd
be a firm or an unconstrained
for a more--
the lower is your wealth
and the more likely
you are to be a worker.
And the thing is, even
when your talent is low,
if your wealth is quite low,
you can't be in business.
These are potentially
profitable entrepreneurs
who are constrained on
the extensive margin
at these parameter values.
Now you say, what
parameter values?
Well, I drew some lines.
The point of the
micro estimation
is to actually be able
to draw those lines based
on the micro data.
So-- oh my goodness.
I don't know how often
this is going to be.
So let me just grab
three equations
and let you focus on this.
Here are the functions,
the structural functions
of the model.
There is a trade-off between
consumption and bequests
under this utility function.
It's basically top Douglas
in today's consumption
and tomorrow's wealth.
This little parameter
here is omega.
Omega is basically going to
determine the savings rate.
And we're going to
have to calibrate it.
This production
function is ugly.
It was meant to be
general, which sounds good.
So it has capital,
it has labor, it
has the square of each of them,
and it has an interaction term.
Unfortunate-- so
it's like translog.
Approximately-- it can
approximate almost any function
reasonably well,
but the problem is,
it carries with it
five parameters.
Alpha, beta, xi, rho, and an
unreadable script, I'm sorry.
I thought it was sigma, but
it doesn't look like sigma.
And this is one of
the regrets that I
have about pushing so
hard in these models,
because it turns
out in hindsight,
we generated data from
that production function
knowing the model,
and it's still
hard to recover
these parameters.
That's something you should
get into the habit of doing.
It's hard enough with
real data, and you already
know, the actual world
is not like your model,
it's an abstraction,
but at least you
ought to make sure that--
and that you can't
really do too,
too much about, because
you have to make decisions
about your model.
But at least you
should make sure
your estimation routine
works well if the model--
if the world were
exactly like the model
and generated the data
that you're about to use.
Anyway, we did the
best we could on that.
And this is this
distribution of setup costs,
the cumulative distribution.
The easiest way to
disentangle this is to say,
suppose m is equal to
0, then this disappears,
and the cumulative distribution
is just rising linearly in x.
In other words, the
density is flat.
So this is just a standard
uniform distribution.
That's also kind of
nice on the diagram,
because although I don't want
to enlarge this, basically
you want to know how many
people of a certain x
there are given a certain b
how many people of a certain x
there are before you go
from firms to workers.
And that's just the
length of that line,
and so a uniform density is
convenient for the sort of--
the geometry of that figure.
However, if m is you
know more than 0,
then you get that squared term.
It just means the distribution
of talent is skewed to the--
really, the distribution of
cost is skewed to the right,
so there are some very
untalented people,
and conversely
when m is below 0.
Now all this big to-do
about micro underpinnings,
what do we see in the data?
Well let's imagine
we see the wage,
and we also see sort
of the net worth
or wealth of the household,
and we know their occupation.
So what does the model predict?
The model predicts that the
occupation is, say, firm--
or yi equals 1 in
a binary sense--
when that distribution
of cost is--
this is-- you should
read this as an x--
is on or below that partition
between workers and firms.
So you add up, as I was just
doing, all those households
with talent less than that.
Likewise, if you're not
going to be yi equal to 1,
you're going to be yi equal
to 0 and a wage earner,
and that's the rest
of the residual mass
or 1 minus this probability.
So what is the likelihood?
So just quick review,
imagine you have a coin,
and usually coins
are fair coins, so--
I'm not sure about
the Super Bowl--
equal probability of
being heads or tails,
and you see a bunch of
data, 4 heads and 6 tails,
and you say, well what
were the odds of that?
Actually, it's a
bit more interesting
if the coin is not
fair, because then it's
not probability 1/2 for
everything that turns up.
But you just basically
take the data,
which is heads, tails, tails,
heads, and so on, or a worker,
firm, firm, worker, and start
adding up the probabilities.
They're independent events.
So this says log here,
but if you undid the log,
you would have the
probability of being a firm,
and then this yi would
just be the 0 or 1,
and when it's equal
to 1, you're just
getting the number of, say,
heads or the number of firms
in the sample, and likewise
for the number of workers.
It's very convenient
to take the logs--
and it takes this form because
logs bring the exponent down
in front of the variable.
It's a cute trick,
too, because you want
to maximize the likelihood.
Logs and levels or
monotone in each other,
you find the max of
one, you're going
to find the max of the other.
So econometricians
usually maximize logs
for reasons like this.
And it turns out with
all that algebra,
those particular
functional forms,
for any set of parameters
in the production function--
alpha, beta, rho, sigma,
xi, et cetera, right?
You can draw all those
lines, and therefore,
determine all these
probabilities.
So for a given guess
about the parameters,
you'll have a certain value
for the log likelihood,
and then you just maximize
that log likelihood
by choosing those parameters.
Essentially the data come
first there on the diagram,
you have sort of wealth--
thousands of data points,
but you have wealth.
And you don't see talent,
that's an unobservable,
but you do see their occupation.
So you're moving
those curves around
to try to fit as many
data points as possible.
Here are the
estimated parameters.
Alpha, beta, xi, rho,
sigma, et cetera, and it's
also estimated
naturally, because that's
kind of telling
you whether there's
a large mass of high or low
cost people in the population.
AUDIENCE: So the line of
matter is just the boundary
between [INAUDIBLE] right?
Divide [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't matter for--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Not in
this case, no we didn't.
Now if I had from the data
households answering-- or firms
answering the question,
are we constrained?
And you could even get
more sophisticated.
Running businesses,
would we like
to invest more given
this shadow price?
I've asked questions like that.
Alp in the macro
lecture half an hour
ago was describing something
like that in the US for firms
right before the--
during the financial crisis.
And you could even do something
on the extensive margin
in principle.
You're worried that those are
lousy questions, like are you
constrained?
But anyway.
It seems to actually
work better in practice
than you think it
might in reality--
in the classroom.
Calibration, not everything can
be gotten from those occupation
choice diagrams.
So-- and actually, we changed
the model just slightly.
We're going to allow
a very slight growth
rate in subsistence
income as if there
were some technological
progress in agriculture.
That savings rate is not
estimable from the micro data
the way we were doing it, and
neither is the subsistence
income in farming.
The level of
subsistence income we
get from a socioeconomic survey
done in Thailand in 1976,
basically matching to
the reservation wage,
there is a slight growth--
very small trend over
time in that wage rate,
so we let it grow exogenously
at 5.5% per year--
less than 1%.
And the Cobb-Douglas says
the savings rate-- and again,
we're going to get--
we're going to set it high,
basically, at basically 1/4,
but that matches evidence--
and you'll see this in China
and many of the countries
you're about to study,
the savings rates are very
high in these countries.
So that's actually realistic.
Learning by doing.
So from the original Bernhardt
and Lloyd-Ellis paper,
you begin to see a little
bit of the dynamics
and also their take on
the development literature
at the time they
wrote the paper.
First of all, why that
myopic savings rate?
Why just care about
today and then tomorrow?
Well, it just helps enormously
in computing the solutions
to these models.
It's like every
day is a new day.
Here's your wealth.
How much am I going to save?
That's a number, that's the
fraction of wealth you're
going to save, and the
rest of it you know you've
got available for consumption.
So after you make your
occupation decision.
So every period,
you kind of have
like a static model where you're
deciding on the occupation.
How well you do, et
cetera, depending
on your occupation
choice and your talent,
determines your end-of-period
wealth, and that you carry over
to tomorrow.
And tomorrow's a new day, the
whole thing starts over again.
No, I don't believe these
guys only live two periods.
Although you will
see, this tension
in the literature between
realism and tractability,
people still use quite heavily
overlapping generations models,
and some--
and I mean like
with three periods.
So it's kind of hard to match
year-to-year data that way,
but you can tell
interesting stories
about the distribution of
wealth and the impact of credit
constraints.
So this is an extreme
version of that.
This is like Rostow's
take-off, you remember?
He worked for Kennedy and--
so this-- he says at first
nothing much is happening,
and then you get
in this transition,
wages begin to rise, but
income and wealth are still
growing first
order, and then you
get the advanced economic
development and wages take off,
and incomes and wealth
basically really, really become
quite high.
And I'll forget to
say it, but if you
let this model run
long enough, it
will converge to a steady
state in which there's
no more any growth in wealth.
It's no longer a growth economy.
And that steady state, because
of this weird assumption
about two periods
and these costs,
you will see people
making transitions.
They will have a certain
wealth and they're
going to be talented or not
talented in certain things,
and they will decide
to, say, forget
what they were doing last period
and do something new today.
So you'll see a lot of churning
in the occupation distribution,
but you will not see
any trends in anything
in their steady state.
This is going to be a
recurrent theme when
we go through these papers as
to which ones are essentially
in steady state, and maybe we're
looking across a cross-section
of economies that vary in some
way, each of which country
is in a steady state
versus transitions.
Today is about
transitions, and I'm not
going to spend a
lot of attention
to this steady state of this
model, which is probably
relatively uninteresting.
OK so now we get to the
financial deepening part.
So what we do is create an
exogenous financial sector
under which everybody's
intermediated.
It's like one of
these dual economies,
except for us, it's like you
have free banks and access
or you have zero access.
It's very extreme.
In the banking
sector, so to speak,
it's not just about
credit, it's about lending.
So there's an equilibrium
interest rate that's
going to clear the market.
More savings is
equal to borrowing.
And now you look at
the return to farmers,
farmers have their
subsistence income,
but they put their
money in the bank,
so they get 1 plus little r or
big R rate of return on that.
Everybody-- when
you have complete--
there's no uncertainty
here, essentially.
So you have a
neoclassical separation
between households and firms,
which essentially means
the financing decisions
of firms have nothing
to do with households.
Another way to put this is, just
put all your money in the bank
and then borrow what you need
if you need to borrow it all.
So all these guys are
putting their money
in the bank,
including the firms,
and then they borrow
back what they need.
Now it is true that the
borrowing and lending
rate are the same
here, and that's how
on getting away with this trick.
Two lectures from now we'll have
a paper focusing quite a bit
on the spread between
borrowing and lending
as a measure of the
cost of intermediation.
This paper doesn't have
that, this paper just
assumes perfectly
costless intermediation,
and these rates are the same.
OK.
So then alpha
fraction of households
are in this intermediate
sector at this date.
So how much is in
the savings accounts?
So you take the
total population,
alpha fraction of the
population intermediated,
everybody's putting--
in that sector
putting b in the bank.
So alpha times b is the saving.
And what's basically
the borrowing level?
Well firms, if you
are firm, you're
going to borrow to
finance both your setup
costs and your capital.
So basically we add
up or integrate up
over the two characteristics--
that is to say the setup costs
themselves as well as wealth.
You will only
integrate up over firms
when x is below some threshold.
Now this threshold no long--
I should actually have drawn
it on the other diagram.
It's a completely flat line.
Whether or not you're
a firm or a worker--
I said this-- has nothing
to do with your wealth,
it just has to do
with your cost.
So if your costs are high,
above this threshold,
you're not going to be a firm.
And if it's below, you are.
If you don't have
a lot of wealth,
you're going to have
to borrow a lot.
So this is sort of
the demand for funds.
And then basically you're going
to set the demand for funds
equal to the supply for funds
and find an interest rate that
does that.
There is an inequality
here only because, again,
the 1 plus little r
could go to 1, basically,
so the cost of
funds is basically
like storing grain in the
backyard, in which case
there's some indeterminacy you
might as well just carry it
over rather than
put it in a bank.
But interest rates can
be higher than that.
And likewise,
employment, we've got--
we just integrate up
the demand for work.
Employment is tricky.
People have jobs.
You're either going
to be a farmer
or a worker or an entrepreneur.
There's only so many
people in the population.
So if the size of the
population is normalized to 1,
you've got basically the
number of entrepreneurs
and the number of work workers.
The number of
workers, it just comes
from the employment
of the existing firms
where l is the labor
hired of a firm, facing R
is the interest rate,
and w is the wage.
There's two sectors
here, intermediated and
non-intermediated.
They're different
from each other,
but the labor market is perfect.
Again, not so credible,
but makes it much easier.
So you can work for
any firm, there's
not even any real
migration cost-- maybe
that cost of living
costs, and that's it.
So you'll be indifferent at
a given wage where you work.
So you would just add
up all the employment,
add up the number
of firms, and again,
lots of the time, this
thing will be equal to 1,
you used up all the
people, and you'll
have to find a wage that equates
the demand and the supply
for workers.
So on Friday, Yan will kind of
talk you through a bit more.
Easy to say, maybe
not so easy to do.
Even though it's a
static model, you
have to find these equilibrium
interest rates and wages that
clear the market.
You need an algorithm
for doing that.
You need to have a good
guess about how to search
and how to iterate.
AUDIENCE: Question?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes?
AUDIENCE: This may
be in all of these.
So I want to think about
investments in human capital.
Should we think of that as--
that goes into x
or should we think
of that as a different
kind of investment which--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
There really isn't
any realistic human
capital in this model.
These guys are choosing
whether to be--
set up a firm or have--
or what occupation.
You could imagine a
model where the choice is
whether or not to go to
school, but it's just not here.
And it's not even
realistic in the sense
that those x's, you might
say, well I went to school,
I'm pretty talented, and I
know how to run a business,
might want to do that.
But that talent can change
from one period to the next,
so it's not great
for human capital.
OK.
So here are income,
savings, labor share,
the fraction of entrepreneurs,
and a measure of inequality--
the Gini--
as both predicted by
the model and what
is actually in the data.
The data are up here, actually.
So this didn't work too well.
Income growth in the
model is always less
than it is in the actual data.
Remember my little
bit for science?
Where I said let's see
how well a model does?
Yeah, we can match
these things much better
if we also choose the
parameters to try to match them,
but we didn't do that,
we're completely under--
it's amazing, it's
doing in some sense,
as well as it does at all--
like look at
inequality, for example.
You can't probably
tell from the back row
the difference between
the model and the data.
There's some intervals here.
Basically, when you
estimate things,
you have standard errors
on the parameter estimate.
So there's a whole
confidence interval
around all those curves I'm
drawing on the occupation
choice.
So we generated lots of
different paths drawing
parameters within standard
confidence intervals.
But the actual mean
path is right here
and the actual Thai
data is right here.
So this inequality kind of is
basically very well-tracked,
and eventually goes down.
When does this start going down?
That's when there
are no more farms.
Well that's kind of the
model version of it.
There's a sharp
increase in the wage
at around 1992 in Thailand.
I think-- I don't know when
the turning point was in China.
But this is pretty typical.
Fraction of entrepreneurs
we're underpredicting,
although eventually it rises.
Labor share would do
quite well, and so on.
So now with the model with
its pluses and minuses,
we can do some
welfare experiments.
And what I want
to do essentially
is a couple of experiments.
RCTs.
One partial equilibrium and
one general equilibrium.
So here's my randomized control
trial for partial equilibrium.
I'm going to take a
household and move it
from the non-intermediated
it sector
and put it in the
intermediated sector
and then look at
the welfare gains.
Now actually, before 1992, the
wage in Thailand is the same,
it's still at the
subsistence level
regardless of this
expanding financial sector.
So it's both a partial and
a general equilibrium model,
but I don't have to worry
about the general equilibrium
effects of the wage.
It's not like I'm giving the
economy intermediation or not.
Or it's equivalent
with having a guy moved
from autarky to
financial intermediation,
because a wage is the same.
So what the hell is this?
This huge spike
here are basically
the gains equivalent--
consumption gains
or wealth gains
for households of low
wealth but high talent.
So I pinpointed them earlier in
the occupation choice diagram.
So they are no
longer constrained.
So there are some
very talented people
who will now set up businesses
and even hire workers and make
a lot of money.
After all, the flip side
of the wage being low
is that when you're a firm, you
don't have to pay high costs.
You make a ton of money.
So these gains are so big that
they make the other things
small in comparison.
Actually, these sort
of orangey people
are switching from workers
to firms, and these blue--
light-blue people, those were--
I don't know if this
will surprise you,
those are inefficient firms
going out of business.
I mean, they're an autarky, not
much to do with their money,
throw it back into the business,
drive the marginal return down
to the carrying costs
of grain, and that's
the best thing other than
being a farmer that you can do.
But when the interest
rate goes up early on--
and early on the interest
rate in this economy
will be high, because there
isn't that much wealth,
and there's relatively high
marginal product in production.
So these lazy, untalented,
richer people--
sorry, lazy was excessive.
They don't have a
choice about it,
they're just not
good at anything.
They take their money and
they put it in the bank
and they get a higher return.
We'll come back to this later
in the class when we actually
come back to RCTs and
IV and all of that,
but there is already
a caution here--
some things are not monotonic.
The treatment effect is not
monotonic in this model.
Intermediation it's a
good thing in the sense
that everyone can earn higher
income at least when there are
no general equilibrium effects.
But the way in which
you earn higher income
may involve occupation shifts--
some people going into
business and some people
going out of business.
So in a very simple
way, you can see
how you would lose
monotonicity of the treatment.
We'll come back to
that in a later day.
So this is a prediction--
oh, now let's jump countries.
I'll go to Mexico.
Actually, I think
the next slide is--
oh, how annoying.
OK, I'm learning.
We won't have this--
I'll try to avoid this
problem in the future.
In Mexico, the
fractions of basically
wage earners, the fraction of
agriculturalists or subsistence
people, and the fraction
of entrepreneurs.
And the earlier one I didn't
show you on that scale
actually shows these can
be slightly different,
but on this scale with
all the occupations,
it works quite well.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
imagine the fractions
in each occupation.
You mentioned some of that--
there's a lot of movement
in cross-occupation type.
That probably is a
[INAUDIBLE] from the data.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, we're not--
AUDIENCE: Times the time.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right.
We're not actually looking at
the panel of a given household
at their career choice
or occupation choice
over many time periods.
We're just only using
the cross-section
to do the estimation.
So even though-- I think your
point is-- even though this
seems to fit well,
beneath this picture,
there may be households
flipping from one to the other
and the model doesn't
say they should.
Actually, when we get to
Buera and Shin and so on,
that will be at center stage.
They're going to be more
realistic about the talent
distribution, and they're going
to even have forward-looking
dynamics so you'll-- they'll
anticipate the way in which
their talent may evolve in the
future and it will remedy this
shortcoming.
Now it looks like I'm
claiming a big success here
in the sense of jumping
New Mexico and all
of a sudden showing you
the outcome after all
the same steps, but let me
show you something else.
So this line is the
model predicted number
of entrepreneurs in the
sector without credit,
and this is the one with credit.
It's bad news.
It's kind of the opposite
of what you think.
Financial autarky turns out
to be better in this sense.
Now normal people don't
show you this stuff.
But I'm showing it
to you for a reason.
And it's in that book
that I mentioned, the one
we're writing on Mexico.
So what went wrong?
Well I went back and I've
been worried about this
for quite a long time.
I went back and looked
at the chapters again.
Am I going to put this
book in the trash can?
And what I realized was
that occupation choice
where you do these probits of--
the variables like credit
weren't even showing up there
as being significant,
whereas they do in Thailand.
So the data-- the micro data
were essentially speaking to me
and I wasn't hearing
it for a while.
It makes the point
of the lecture,
which is you've got to take the
micro underpinning seriously.
And I followed an algorithm as
if I'd figured something out
in Thailand and I
could do it in Mexico.
But now I know why it wasn't
working so well in Mexico.
It doesn't tell you what the
next step is, by the way,
but clearly LEB isn't going
to work there very well.
AUDIENCE: But isn't the firm
bigger In the credit sector?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: In the model?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The firm is--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
the model doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: No, but--
so if there is a lower
percentage [INAUDIBLE]
but the firm's bigger,
that's fine, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh.
All right, I don't
have firm size.
I'll go back and
look if we actually--
oh, I should say also
something related.
We have-- like I
have for Thailand,
and it's available
to you on Dataverse,
we have a massive
archive of Mexican data.
It should be on Dataverse,
and I meant to include--
I hope there is included
already Jorge Moreno's summary
of the Mexican data.
And this book will
kind of give you
a sense of the great variety
of data we have and--
I can go back and look and
see whether we actually
plotted firm size.
OK, another model.
So this is the one with
endogenous financial deepening,
and I'm leading off with a
picture that should remind you
of the lecture of last time,
which is this trade-off
between--
potentially between
growth and levels and also
the variability of growth.
In this case, at low
levels of income,
you have higher
variability, which
is kind of a fact that seems
to be true in the data.
However, this is a
model-generated path
in which over time, per-capita
income is going to be changing,
and from those
points on, is going
to change the
statistics of the model
in terms of expected future
growth and the variance
of the growth.
So how does this model work?
Well it is-- this one
is forward-looking.
So households don't just care
about today and tomorrow,
they care about the
discounted expected future,
and they care about, in this
case, the log of consumption
at every date.
In a minute we're going
to talk about some-- only
slightly more general
power functions.
Beta is the discount
rate, and we're
going to simplify sectors
and occupation choices,
almost like telling the usual
riskless and risky asset.
Rather than thinking
of them as occupations,
there's a riskless asset.
So when you invest at t
minus 1 a certain amount,
you get delta times that amount
back in the following period.
A constant rate of return,
and the risky technology
when you invest at the
amount i at t minus 1,
you get it back plus
or minus 2 components.
There's an aggregate
shock, theta t, no i on it.
It's common across
every household.
It's like aggregate risk.
And there's an epsilon,
which does have--
this is household
j, sorry, not i.
i as investment, j is household.
This epsilon j is the
idiosyncratic shock
that's hitting household
j, and definitely
different across
different households.
So if you're lucky
enough or you've
paid the money to be in the club
of the financial intermediary,
there's an advantage--
two advantages, actually.
Information and pooling
of idiosyncratic risk.
So the return you get at t
minus 1 for carrying stuff over
is the maximum, largely,
of either the safe return
or the risky return.
But the risky return
isn't risky anymore.
This model goes too far, you
see it perfectly in advance,
so you can kind of
pick off what to do.
It's an extreme version
of intermediaries
have an information advantage
and they can advise clients
because they have
that advantage.
Well not quite, there's
kind of an intermediation
cost and that's gamma.
So this is a wedge, this
is in inefficiency--
it's not modeled in a deep
way, but it uses up resources.
And we'll come back
to that momentarily.
And the other thing
is, it's costly to get
into the investment club,
and it cost basically alpha.
Not the alpha of the previous
slide, just some new number.
There's perfect competition
among financial intermediaries,
they might be tempted
to try to make profits,
but they're going
to be driven down
to basically making
people pay the fixed cost
to enter the financial
system at the true cost
and to give them a return
that exactly covers the wedge
and is otherwise equal to
the real rate of return
on the investment.
So where did the epsilon go?
I said they got the risk--
I didn't quite say it right.
You get the risky
thing for sure,
not only because theta,
but because these epsilons
disappear.
And the epsilons
are pooling across
many, many, many households.
It's IID, essentially,
so it goes to 0
as you have more
and more households.
So it's like a mutual fund.
It's not just a bank
with fixed borrowing,
it's more like equity.
You put your money
in the bank, it
gets kind of the average
return on the bank's portfolio,
you might want to borrow
some to finance investment,
but that's kind of separate.
So this looks like a
discrete choice problem.
And if you bear with me, It's
not as bad as it may seem.
Suppose at day t, you've
already made the decision
to keep yourself out of
the financial system.
So then you have
a value function
that depends on your
wealth, which is not
b here, but k at day
t, and you're going
to decide what to do with that.
You can save some of it, and the
difference between what you had
and what you save, you eat.
And the amount that you
save, you get to put into--
some fraction into the risky
thing and some fraction
into the safe thing.
Now you're not in the
bank by the decision
here, so you're definitely
going to be experiencing
this idiosyncratic risk.
It may make the save return
more attractive, but we'll see.
OK, so then the next
period rolls around,
and then at the
very, very beginning,
you kind of get to
decide whether to join
the financial system
or not at that date.
You're forward-looking.
So the value to, say, not
joining the financial system
is this W that was over here.
W means withdrawn or
not participating.
But if you do decide
to join, you're
going to get the other branch,
the value of participating,
and that's basically going to
be something called V. However,
not quite V, because that
instant that you join,
you're going to have to subtract
off those fixed costs q.
And in this model, it's once
and never more, actually.
Once you pay to be in,
you stay in forever.
So this could have been a
simpler slide in the sense
that once you join and
you join the V branch,
you'll never again have
to choose to withdraw,
you'll just stay in the
financial system-- you reap
all the advantages of
information and risk pooling
and there's no reason to leave.
You'd have to change this
model to get disintermediation.
But the focus here was on
increasing intermediation.
So this is probably
something you've seen--
I'm not quite so
sure what you've
had in your other courses.
This is a dynamic
discrete choice model.
And basically, you have
this value function W
for low wealth.
It's the highest
curve, and then you
say, no, well this is above it.
No, not really, because
at the instant you join,
you have to subtract q.
So you take this V
and subtract q off
of the capital level that
brings the whole curve down.
So where these-- to this.
So where this thing
crosses, that's
kind of the key entry point.
At k at 15, given the way
I've drawn these curves,
to the left of 15, you
won't be participating,
and to the right
a 15, you will be.
Now remember, there's not a
whole lot of heterogeneity
either, sort of wealth
is the key unique state
variable at the
beginning of the period,
so wealth alone is going
to predict if the model is
accurate, whether or not
you're in the financial system,
and I'll come back to that.
Here, here are these savings
functions and portfolio
choices, and 15--
or I guess I said this
is kind of the key mark.
One thing that makes sense is
the dynamics, which is you're
saving up more and more in
advance for this eventual entry
into the financial system.
Exactly when you
will go in depends
on the sequence of shocks
that you experience,
and you may experience setbacks
that push your wealth down
even though ex ante your
investment decision made sense.
But kind of slowly
over time, there's
this pressure moving
off to the right.
So it makes-- but there's
discounting, right?
So you don't want to save
up too much early on,
you kind of want to
be close, and then you
don't want to take all
that fixed cost out
of your wealth at that date,
you save up to finance it.
This is unexpected ex ante.
So the closer you get,
the riskier you go.
So you would think
people who can't
diversify outside the
financial system would
be doing the safe thing.
But actually, this fixed cost
is creating a non-convexity.
If you remember
way back when you
see Friedman and Savage,
sort of that utility function
which is not concave everywhere,
well you've got two branches.
You've got this value
function for participating
and the value function
for not participating.
And in principle, they kind of
cross like a butterfly, right?
So then you're getting this
non-concave part in the middle,
and that's creating this kind of
risk behavior where they start
doing riskier or risky
things that kind of span--
take a chance of
grabbing the brass ring
and bootstrapping up
to a higher level.
We didn't see that coming.
Actually, those diagrams
look like they paced smoothly
into one another in
those value functions.
That's after this
randomization is going on.
Otherwise-- and so
the butterfly kind of
disappears, but only
after this randomization.
So let me just say a few more in
terms of the actual functional
forms.
Constant relative risk aversion
of essentially degree sigma.
Beta, I said, was
the discount rate.
Sorry, this is now
xi rather than theta.
But in any event,
we have to specify--
and they're uniformly
distributed-- again,
not my favorite choice anymore.
If something is
uniformly distributed,
you have to have an
upper and lower bound.
So we have picked up two more
parameters for the epsilon
distribution, and even something
for the risky distribution.
So discrete choice-- d for,
I guess, discrete choice,
basically you're
going to enter or not
enter depending on whether
your value of participating
is higher than not
participating and vice versa.
The model that
those parameters is
going to give you the k star,
which, again in the example,
was 15.
In general, k star is
going to depend on this--
all these list of parameters,
and this list of parameters--
the fixed cost, the discount
rate, aversion and utility,
the wedge in
intermediation, the upper
and lower bounds on
those distributions,
all of those things--
theta for GI-- basically
determine k star.
And k star is going to determine
whether you at a given wealth
choose to enter or not enter.
So I'll skip this,
but basically there's
a complicated way in
which the parameters
of the model through
the lens of the model
are generating this
sort of threshold value.
And likewise, therefore, you can
imagine, if at a given wealth,
you kind of see the fractions
participating and not
participating in
the cross-section,
that you would be able
to sort of invert things
and estimate these parameters.
It's a bit tricky because
that theta, the level
of the aggregate
shock kind of matters,
so we have to integrate
up over that, too.
But when we do the estimation
using a socioeconomic survey,
the papers online, we
ended up estimating--
and actually, comfortingly,
a lot of the parameters
make sense.
The discount rate's close
to 1, but not exactly.
A degree of risk aversion
is like almost the log case
and the depreciation rate was
4% and so on and so forth,
quite remarkable.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And so is that--
am I reading this correctly?
Is that gamma was
estimated to be 1?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
In this case, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So with that imply efficient--
like there's no wedge?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, no wedge.
Yeah, that-- I'll come
back to that momentarily.
So again, we can
simulate the model--
and under various estimated
or robustness checks,
parameter values--
to get the growth rate,
the participation rate,
and the tile index
of inequality.
Now one caution on
the growth rate,
and I always have to
check to make sure--
this model has aggregate shocks.
So if you integrate out
over the expected shocks,
you're going to get a
smoother growth rate
path than in the actual data.
And what is it that
I have to check?
I always have to go back
and see whether this
was one where we use
simulated values of theta
or we took the average
over those thetas.
We missed this upturn
here and the growth rate,
and that's related to the fact
that financial participation
goes flat right here.
This model's great
at the trends.
It gives you this very smooth,
ever-increasing participation
in the financial
system, and actually, it
gives you for a
while a good shot
at the increasing inequality
as those firms made
a lot more money, but
it misses the downturn.
In fact, there are
no real prices,
there's nothing like a
wage or an interest rate,
that's a defect.
And so it's almost like a
linear world, in some sense,
and we can't get inequality
to go down in this model,
but we can get the
trends right for a while.
This participation
thing is going
to bring me back to the wedge.
So what do we do?
We're going to do a policy
experiment, basically.
We look at the government's
control of the banking system
in terms of the ratio of credit.
It's moving around a bit,
but essentially it's flat,
it goes up, and then
it comes down again.
This is the liberalization
and this is the retrenchment
that happened before it.
So what we do is, we vary
that parameter gamma.
It's not going to be
costless intermediation.
In fact, we're going
to subtract off--
I think it was
something like 3% or 4%
when the intermediation is
being done by government banks.
And we don't change
the model otherwise.
And amazingly, we get this
almost perfectly right.
So we can actually get the
slowdown in the economy
as a function of this, quote,
bad policy experiment where
the government, for
one reason or another,
essentially took over
the banking system.
By the way, we don't do very
well with growth differences
even after liberalization,
and we can--
and the reason is partly
because, at least through
the lens of OLS
regressions, it's--
I've alluded to this before--
it's just basically junk.
I mean, it's not a
stationary model.
The decision rules
are stationary,
but aggregates like
growth rates are not.
And you can use
this value functions
to back out the welfare gains.
There are a number
of ways to do that.
One thing we could do
is just surprise people.
They think the banking system
is going to stay restricted,
and they've made
their dynamic plans,
and then we surprise
them and liberalize.
And they're better off, and we
can calculate through the value
functions.
It's a bit complicated
and I'm not
going to take you
through these slides,
but the welfare gains
can be quite large.
Now we can imagine
surprising them,
like varying that wedge or
varying the fixed cost and it
actually matters a bit, and we
can take this model to Mexico
and it does pretty well with
the trend of the growth rate,
but around 1992, Mexico
had yet another crisis.
And not surprising, this model
is just very ill-equipped
to handle that kind of stuff.
Actually, things
started going better
with Vicente Fox around 2002.
We could restart the model
over here and it will do well.
But it's not going to explain--
this is why Mexico
is still poor.
I mean, they go upstairs,
they go upstairs,
and then they fall down again.
And they've been doing this
since the early '80s, you know?
Now hopefully they're not
going to fall down again.
But the model--
I promised you
shortcomings, right?
This model is not designed to
get at sudden stops or things
along that line.
So the last thing I
want to show you quickly
is another kind of experiment.
Instead of going to a
new country like Mexico,
we started to look interior
to the country of Thailand.
This is a picture
of basically wealth
using a principal component.
You can see in
and around Bangkok
and going north to Chiang Mai--
the wealth corridor, if
you want, of the country,
these green things are the
provinces of my survey.
And looking at them
again, you can actually
see where the villages are,
you can see the road network,
at least on major highways, you
can see the district centers.
And I promised I
would ask you this.
I mentioned it before.
If you have an interest in
going through some of the GIS
capabilities, I'm more
than happy to schedule
an extra session.
I have to check my GIS person.
I see some of you
shaking your heads.
You don't all have to go,
so that's enough for me.
So let me check with her
and maybe we can possibly
do that Friday of
next week, but it
would be over and above the
regular recitation section.
And so here is a
picture of where
the businesses are in Thailand.
And through this GIS,
something called the Moran,
you can see whether areas, which
have high levels of enterprise,
are surrounded by other areas
with high levels of enterprise
or low levels surrounded by low.
And so you see this quite
salient geographic picture.
And here, we took levels
of enterprise in 1986
and looked at the growth
rate of enterprise
between 1986 and 1996.
This area in here, the
colors are a bit pale--
it doesn't come out too well--
are areas of
convergence in the sense
that they started at
high levels but then they
shrink to lower levels.
This area around it,
though, these reds, those
are areas of agglomeration.
They have high levels
and high growth rates.
There's an ever-increasing
concentration of enterprise.
These pink areas are catch-up
areas along the corridor which
had low levels, and now they're
gaining a lot of enterprise.
And these blue areas out here
are kind of like the boonies.
They have low levels
and low growth rates.
So it's not a uniform picture.
In fact, you can take
this down to the provinces
and look in the data at
the areas of agglomeration
and relative low
levels, and then that
looks like almost
the same picture.
That's a
model-generated picture.
So we actually projected--
took Lloyd-Ellis and Bernhardt
and projected it down
at the village level,
and here you can
see agglomeration.
It's not exactly identical.
There are certain
predictions in the model
that don't happen in
the data, but largely
these sort of favorable areas--
a subset of the candidate
of favorable areas
are the ones that actually start
growing like crazy in Thailand.
And here at that same level
is Greenwood in Jovanovic.
And here, these
red areas are areas
where the model
overpredicts the data,
and the green areas
are places where
the model is underpredicting.
In other words, these
red areas, which turn out
to be the same urban areas,
Greenwood and Jovanovic
is predicting they should have
more banks than they actually
do.
So in some sense, even
though they're higher wealth,
they're underserved relative to
what the model would predict.
And these green
areas, those are areas
where there's more access
to credit than Greenwood
and Jovanovic would predict.
Now it turns out
this story has to do
with the interplay
between commercial banks
that operate in urban areas and
the bank for agriculture which
is operating in rural
areas, and we'll
come back to that in the
last lecture of the class.
So I'm done, essentially.
I'll just point you to
the rest of the slides.
Basically we did kind
of a rigorous comparison
of the successes
and the failures.
So you can actually go
through each of the models
and see on which data
which model's doing well
and which data models
are doing poorly,
which feeds into the
issue of model selection
and next steps in the research.
So OK, with that, I'm
slightly two minutes beyond.